[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et bienvenue en direct
dans ce numéro très spécial de face à
Baba aujourd'hui nous recevons le
ministre des Sports
[Musique]
pourquoi vous êtes venus dans cette
émission vous savez que c'est une
émission à risque parce que c'est une
parole libre parce que c'est une parole
qui s'adresse aux jeunes parce que c'est
une parole qui est comprise partout
parce que je considère que tout le monde
a droit à être écouté tout le monde a le
droit d'être entendu et parce que je
pense qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a plus un
moyen de s'exprimer puis un moyen de
communiquer mais des moyens dont vous
faites partie c'est un moyen moderne je
vous en remercie merci monsieur
ce soir j'allais pouvoir poser vos
questions à Monsieur le Ministre qui est
là en direct ceux de leurs mots merci
d'être là alors il y a des gens des
Français les Français vous en avez vu
dernièrement pas des comme ça mais
non pas comme c'est français qui sont là
pour vous poser des questions je vous le
dis vous poseront toutes les questions
bien sûr vous répondrez bien sûr sans
détour surtout avec beaucoup de
franchises car vous savez aujourd'hui je
pense que la franchise vaut mieux qu'une
mauvaise nouvelle c'est pas tout compris
plutôt que de mentir pour annoncer une
mauvaise nouvelle les Français sont
prêts
[Applaudissements]
première question monsieur vous venez
d'où je viens de Bourgogne merci vous
appelez comment et je m'appelle
mais je reste ce crédible quand même je
peux déjà répondre à Monsieur non je ne
me tape pas de [ __ ] voilà
ma question vous n'avez jamais trompé
votre amour m'avez-vous eu des rapports
tarifs justement
ah c'est une bonne question est-ce que
j'ai déjà payé pour où est-ce qu'on m'a
déjà payé
pour alors il se trouve que payer pour
quelque chose que ce soit du sexe autre
chose je ne le fais jamais d'accord des
raisons d'éthiques je ne paye rien ni
les restaurants ni les hôtels ni les
voyages
non monsieur ministre je vous
rappellerai quand même que très souvent
le rapport tarifait coûte moins cher que
de payer le restaurant le machin tout ça
et d'avoir à faire parfois à un amateur
ça c'est vrai donc des fois tu payes tes
plus tranquille ça coûte moins cher et
tu te fais pas rayer le casque
monsieur
bonsoir Je m'appelle Géraldine je viens
de Toulouse j'habite aujourd'hui à Paris
bonsoir monsieur le ministre vous avez
toujours été très franc très sincère
avec les Français vous avez toujours
parlé de votre désir de votre sexualité
ce soir si vous deviez passer une nuit
d'amour choisir
Raymond ou Delphine
j'apprécie d'abord l'auteur aussi
bien vous aurez pris car vous êtes à la
fois intelligente et belle et je dois
dire que tous les
français
vous avez des gens de qualité autour de
ce plateau bien sûr tu devais répondre
votre Raymond choisir et Delphine le
choix d'abord très difficile j'aimerais
le dire bien sûr car les deux sont très
beaux les deux ont la vérité la vérité
alors bien sûr je me tape Delphine mais
10 fois
[Applaudissements]
et dans tous les sens et dans tous les
sens
j'ai l'impression que les Français sont
d'accord avec vous merci
sont d'accord avec Monsieur le Ministre
ce soir nous sommes en direct 18h59
une émission particulière ce soir mais
ça ne veut pas dire que Raymond est
moche bien sûr bien sûr merci Delphine
[Rires]
des sondages de république démocratique
de Congo entre Delphine et
pardon
effectivement vous êtes un peu de
français
bien sûr voilà
c'est là que le stabil dire aux Français
c'est là que le pluriel amour peut
intervenir
en même temps
[Applaudissements]
chemise en tout cas vous avez euh mon
prénom noté qu'est-ce qu'il y a de mon
prénom après je peux te dire merci
on a une autre question pour Monsieur
Miss oui une question d'un jeune
Allemand
Mathieu j'aimerais qu'on revienne
monsieur le ministre j'aimerais qu'on
revienne sur ce parcours sur ces 30 ans
de carrière pas ouf
vous le plus fier d'avoir animé ouf ou
d'avoir joué dans la pub Trésor de
Kellogg's
sur des questions qui n'ont rien fait
qui sont un petit peu aigris qui sont de
la jalousie mais qui ont le droit de
poser leurs questions et ne pas leur
répondre respecter tous les Français
au dessus des parties
oh mais c'est vrai
dois-je répondre à cette chose à cette
chose en couleur
merci oui monsieur monsieur monsieur
monsieur monsieur
bonsoir Je m'appelle Gilles je viens de
banlieue parisienne monsieur le ministre
vous avez face à vous 8 français vous
venez de dire que vous respectez
énormément les gens pouvez-vous
sincèrement me dire parmi ces 8 combien
vous en détestez et pourquoi
déjà le ministre déjà je tiens à dire
que j'ai tous les prénoms bien sûr et
que déjà vous aimez votre pays vous
aimez la France c'est une évidence on ne
fait pas ce métier pour autre chose que
pour une vocation si vous croyez moi
dans le privé on prend beaucoup moins de
coups on a beaucoup moins d'argent mais
prendre des coups j'aime bien ça alors
[Applaudissements]
à mon parti à mon parti alors qui je
déteste alors je dis juste le nombre je
dis pas qui bien sûr
[Rires]
2 pas de langue de bois monsieur je suis
dedans
c'est la seule chose qu'on puisse
affirmer en effet delphine est sortie
delphine est sorti totalement Delphine
de ma vie moi je voulais savoir Monsieur
le Ministre pourquoi cette évolution la
question de comportement face à ma
personne justement parce que je suis
sortie de tout ça alors d'abord parce
que je trouve que vous faites des
émissions
beaucoup plus qualitatives qu'auparavant
sans doute je dois le dire aussi parce
que vous êtes proche de Valéry bene de
moi de personnes d'expérience et que
vous avez su
bien sûr c'est Dieu a donné deux
oreilles et une bouche si pour écouter
deux fois plus qu'on entend voilà donc
merci
[Applaudissements]
progresser tu es très jolie et puis
c'est vrai qu'il y a eu ce qu'on appelle
le contact bien sûr le gendarme se marie
le de Funès et c'est vrai que quand on
s'est touché ça crée une alchimie
exactement et ça je dis très souvent là
c'est parti que je fais quand tu vas sur
des sites de rencontres pour des garçons
et tout ça ou tu peux rencontrer des
gens en 2009
j'ai un très bon ami qui va parfois tout
ça et c'est vrai que parfois tu
rencontres quelqu'un qui est très très
beau mais vraiment c'est une bombe du
coup avec il ne se passe rien mais rien
rien rien il y a la chimie l'odeur il y
a un truc qui passe ou pas je pensais
qu'il se passerait rien avec Delphine et
en fait c'est passé il y a le truc qui
traverse si on avait couché ensemble ça
aurait été vraiment explosif là on n'a
pas pu pour des questions de séquence
mais ça aurait été
bien entendu que partir remise bien sûr
l'américaine oui il va poser une
question non merci en français je crois
qu'elle fait partie peut-être des deux
que vous détestez oh non je ne sera pas
permis de de comment
on est en voie de guérison également ah
d'accord donc je ne vois pas qui est le
deuxième en tout cas le premier on l'a
[Applaudissements]
alors Monsieur le Ministre où vous voyez
vous dans deux ans
[Rires]
chez lui
je pense vraiment que dans un autre un
ou deux ans tu vas te lasser tu vas
surtout prendre des places énormes dans
le groupe Canal et tu feras d'autres
choses et c'est bien normal après 11 ou
12 ans il te faudra un disciple Casta
c'est pas possible pour des raisons
physiques bon rien il entend rien mais
c'est vrai
a beaucoup de talent mais physiquement
non plus il faut rester 3h debout oui
sur cette petite phrase qui fait
polémique que vous avez prononcer tout à
l'heure au maquillage à 18h22 de toute
façon Cyril c'est mon petit un jour
aussi il sera mon chroniqueur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
surtout c'est de ne pas perdre espoir de
continuer de d'y croire de continuer de
croire que le meilleur est toujours
devant c'est ce que je dis toujours en
souvenirs est toujours devant
n'ayez pas peur surtout soyez confiants
et puis surtout n'oubliez pas que votre
bonheur c'est mon bonheur
[Applaudissements]